merci d'avoir accepté ce petit détail
est vous ferai avec plaisir parce que
c'est quoi je veux rien est trompeur je
le sens absolument
[Musique]
alors je commence toujours par un petit
compliment pour mettre à l'aise comme
acteur et comme vous êtes un sacré
craque et vous me fait l'effet d'une
boîte d'aphrodisiaques c'est pour la
rime en est d'accord a uniquement oui
j'aimais et puis moi non plus alors à
quand on est en amour c'est connu je
suis à ses novices
alors en cette matière me rendriez ou
services c'est pour la rime en vis à la
balade a également cher claude ils sont
fourrés derrière voilà alors dans un des
fonds se présente donc moi mon métier
c'est midinettes
j'assume et mon actu c'est d'essayer de
ne plus être célibataire endurci voir
racornie mais bon c'est pas évident
alors vous votre métier cet acteur et
réalisateur et votre actu donc c'est les
vétos un film que j'ai adoré parce qu'il
est sur la transmission c'est sur un
métier dont on parle peu dans cette
situation là c'est à dire celles des
métaux mais on est en milieu rural cd
joli personnage parce que même si je
pense qu'ils nous ressemblent c'est à
dire que les gens projettent quelque
chose sur le film
ça fait ça sauver une vie bach est bon
ça tu sauras on va faire une petite
interview veto je dis que vous vous
demandez vous si c'est de l'art ou du
cochon mais voir justement vous allez
comprendre
en amour je traverse une période de
vaches maigres vous avez une solution
pour me sortir de là et que je vois
enfin le loup
oui en tous les cas certainement qu'il
va falloir s'exposer quoi tend la main
j'ai fait savoir ouais c'est là que
c'est très clair assez assez clair
respect alors peut-être je peux le faire
faut leur dire si vous deviez faire une
petite annonce variés comme leboncoin ou
ebay par exemple pour me pour me qu'elle
fait qu'est ce que vous diriez aucune
elecam de tournoi donc je dirais aucune
hésitation aucune hésitation foncé
allez-y c'est vraiment les algues
marines ont rencontré vous parlez vous
verrez était petit à petit ça peut être
chouette serait assez addictif un jeu
sans vous ai manqué ce sera une bonne
année quand c'est pas vu oui il ya un et
une forme de manque alors je fêterai
gaffe à ça parce que pour ma santé
mentale je vais pas non plus que vous
allez n'y a pas de changement pour
arriver à vous déshabiller sas et voilà
ça reste de la vie privée on a dit qu'on
parlait pas de sens mais mais voilà
alors bien sûr je ne casse pas trois
pattes à un canard mais si je vous fais
mon avis de biche et maje bouche en
cul-de-poule est-ce que vous j'ai une
chance de plaire à nico le veto mais
mais mais je peux tout faire c'est pas
facile on en même temps mais bien sûr
évidemment pourquoi non ouais bah ouais
je n'avais pas d'à priori éviter la
bouche en cul-de-poule je pensais pas ce
cas plus séduisant ça tombe bien je sais
pas combien la faire alors je saute du
coq à l'âne puisque l'aca que je peux
sauter et je vous rappelle donc qu'il
faut absolument aller voir les vétos ça
sort le 1er janvier
absolument je trouve que c'est une belle
façon de commencer l'année parce que
vraiment ça parle de transmission c'est
important on n'a pas beaucoup parlé
c'est un film sur la transmission aussi
j'en ai marre de réparer toutes les
colonies alors je finis un petit un
petit qcm vous savez questions à choix
multiples vies c'est ce qu'on peut
s'embrasser petit a maintenant petit
bébé quand les poules auront des dents
j'ai mon petit c est ce que vous mettez
totalement votre veto alors je suis
obligé de mettre mon veto parce que j'ai
mon épouse mais sinon ce serait
évidemment c'est parce qu'on s'attache
c'est ça le problème c'est sinon hommes
n'osent pas parce qu'ils ont trop peur
après de s'attacher à bâle alors on fait
un petit coucou à votre épouse qui joue
votre épouse dans le film ce qui est
plus pratique
exactement combien merci bonne
journée
[Musique]